منذ دخولنا الى مدينه غازي عنتاب شاهدنا
الكثير من
اللاجئين كثير من النازحين اللاجئين
السوريين والنازحين ايضا الذين هدمت
منازلهم كاد المنزل وهم منتشرين في انحاء
المدينه بعبر خيام انما تم اعطائهم من قبل
المنظمات او حتى منظمات الاغاثيه او حتى
عبر جهودهم الخاصه حصلوا عليها ولكن حتى
الان هنالك تستمر بجانب عمليات الاغاثه
والمساعدات عمليات التنقيب بجانب هذه
العمليات هي مستمره في الحقيقه صحيح ان
عمليات التنقيب لا تزال مستمره منذ اربعه
ايام الا ان فرص الحصول او استخراج ناجين
اصبحت
نسبه ضئيله الى حد ما ولكن في هذا الموقع
تحديدا كان قبل قليل تم سماع اصوات لاشخاص
في داخل هذا
الركام فبالتالي يتم العمل بشكل مباشر من
قبل كافه
العاملين على رفع هذه الانقاذ بين الفتره
والاخرى يتم السكوت مباشره اسكات كل هذه
الاليات
وايضا كانها اشبه بلحظه صمت فاطمه يتم
سماع الاصوات من
نعم ليتم سماع الاصوات من الداخل في
الحقيقه من داخل هذه
الركام حيث تم سماع عدد من الاصوات لا يتم
حتى الان معرفه ما اذا كان وضعهم الصحي
كيف هم هل هم
احياء بشكل كامل او عفوا احياء ام متضررين
ومصابين بشكل بالغ ولكن يتم العمل على
استخراجهم قبل فوات الاوان او حتى قبل ان
يكون هنالك ساعات كثيره على بقائهم
هذه الاصوات
منذ ساعه من الان الجميع هنا يؤكد بانه
استمع لاصوات في داخل هذا الركام بالتالي
نحن عندما وصلنا وجدنا الجميع متوقف وكانه
يستمعون لحاجه ما ولكن
بداوا بالعمل منذ دقائق قليله وبدات
الاليات تعمل لاستخراج من سمعوا اصواتهم
في الداخل خصوصا ان كما تشاهدين في
المنطقه الاخرى هنالك ايضا منطقه
هادمه او عماره منهدمه لا يوجد العمل
عليها كثيرا
اعمال
التنقيب ليست كما هي هنا كالعمل كخليه نحل
لانه الاصوات هناك انقطعت ولم يتم سماع
الكثير من الاصوات خلال ربما اقل من يوم
يومين لم يتم سماع اصوات فيتم يتم التركيز
على الاماكن التي يتم سماع اصوات فيها
بالاضافه الى بعض الاخرى التي يتم العمل
عليها كما تشاهدين هنا في الجانب يعملون
على بعض الحجاره التي استخرجوها من هذا
المنزل لاعب حقيقه ما الذي يعملون بتحديدا
ولكن يبدو انهم يستخرجون بعض الاشياء التي
تساعدهم على الحصول على بعض المعلومات او
حتى استخدامها في عمليات التنقيب